O termo teletransporte quântico pode soar como coisa de ficção científica, mas como vamos falar no episódio de hoje
do Kiskit na Sala de Aula, é uma técnica muito real e muito útil para comunicação e
redes quânticas. Bem-vindo ao Qiskit na sala de aula. Nesta série, vamos usar o Qiskit para explorar alguns conceitos fundamentais
comumente abordados em cursos relacionados à computação quântica. Cada vídeo é acompanhado por um módulo interativo
com link na descrição abaixo, então não deixe de conferir. O teletransporte é meio que um trope de ficção científica e fantasia
neste ponto. Uma pessoa ou objeto desaparece de um local e aparece instantaneamente em outro lugar.
Por mais incrível que isso seria, infelizmente, esse tipo de teletransporte pelo menos é impossível. Quebraria o limite cósmico
de velocidade. Nada pode viajar mais rápido do que a luz. Mas o teletransporte quântico é
possível. No teletransporte quântico, informações em vez de matéria podem ser transmitidas entre dois
locais distantes. Tudo que você precisa é de um par de partículas entrelaçadas, uma em cada site, e uma forma de comunicar informações clássicas
entre os dois sites. Este protocolo foi desenvolvido em 1993 por uma equipe
de cientistas quânticos, incluindo Charles Bennett da IBM. Eles o chamaram de teletransporte quântico porque, semelhante à
versão de ficção científica, a informação quântica desapareceu de um local e apareceu em outro local distante
sem nunca percorrer o espaço intermediário. Pode parecer mágica, mas como vamos ver, não há nada
misterioso ou mágico nisso. É possibilitado pelo fenômeno do entrelaçamento quântico junto com a
comunicação clássica. Hoje vamos percorrer o protocolo de teletransporte quântico e como ele funciona. E então vamos colocá-lo em
ação em um computador quântico real para teletransportar o estado de um qubit de um lado de um processador quântico IBM para
o outro. Então é assim que o teletransporte quântico funciona. Suponha que temos duas pessoas Alice e Bob que estão separadas
por uma grande distância. Digamos que Alice tem um qubit. Vamos chamar o qubit de Q apenas por conveniência. E ele está em algum
estado quântico desconhecido sq onde alpha 0 e alpha 1 são números
complexos. Alice quer enviar seu estado para Bob, mas ela não tem como enviar o próprio qubit. Pode ser que
ele esteja muito longe, ou talvez ela nem saiba exatamente onde Bob está, então ela não sabe para onde enviá-lo. Por sorte,
os amigos já compartilham um par de qubits entrelaçados A e B, onde Alice tem o qubit A e Bob tem o qubit B. E
esses qubits estão entrelaçados. Por entrelaçados, quero dizer que mesmo que os dois qubits estejam separados por uma grande
distância, seus estados estão correlacionados de uma forma que a física clássica não consegue explicar. Esse par entrelaçado é
algo chamado Ebit, que podemos usar como recurso na computação e comunicação quânticas.
Neste caso, Alice pode usar o EBIT como recurso para transmitir suas informações quânticas para Bob. Para ver como, vamos
começar escrevendo o estado conjunto de todos esses três qubits onde ordenei os qubits um pouco arbitrariamente
neste ponto, mas essa ordenação será conveniente quando executarmos nosso experimento no Kiskit. No Qiskit, a forma padrão de
ordenar os qubits é da direita para a esquerda. Então, o estado do qubit zero aparecerá à direita.
Vamos expandir um pouco o estado e reescrevê-lo assim. Então o primeiro passo no nosso protocolo de teletransporte é
Alice entrelaçar seu qubit de dados com sua metade do qubit EBIT usando um gate C knot. Um C knot ou controlled KN
gate vai mudar o estado de um qubit, o qubit alvo, dependendo do estado de outro qubit, o qubit de controle.
Se o qubit de controle estiver no estado zero, então nada acontece com o alvo. E se o qubit de controle estiver no
estado um, então o qubit alvo é invertido. Então neste caso, o qubit de dados Q de Alice será o qubit de controle e
seu qubit Ebit A será o qubit alvo. Então os dois primeiros termos não mudaram nada pelo C knot, mas os
dois últimos termos mudaram porque o qubit de controle Q estava no estado um. Então Alice
aplicaria um gate Hadamard ao seu qubit de dados Q que leva o estado 0 ao estado 1/2 0 + 1 e o estado 1 a
1 sobre 2 0 -1. Vou pular um pouco de álgebra simples aqui que você pode tentar completar por conta própria se quiser.
Mas depois de reorganizar alguns termos você vai obter um estado que parece assim. Então agora o estado entrelaçado de três qubits de Alice e Bob
parece uma bagunça completa. Mas veja o que acontece se Alice medir os dois qubits dela. O estado de três
qubits vai colapsar parcialmente para um desses quatro
termos. E em cada caso, Bob ficará com um estado de superposição com amplitudes relacionadas ao
estado inicial desconhecido de Alice. Lembre-se de que as amplitudes são alpha 0 e alpha 1. Então
por exemplo, se Alice medir os dois qubits como zero, então o estado de Bob vai colapsar para este termo, o estado
desconhecido original que Alice queria teletransportar. Mas se Alice medir zero no qubit A e um no qubit Q, então o estado de Bob
será este. Esse estado pode ser transformado no estado original do qubit Q se Bob
aplicar um Zgate, que vai inverter esse sinal aqui. Mas Bob não vai saber fazer isso
até ele saber o que Alice mediu. Então o próximo passo no protocolo é Alice ligar para Bob e dizer a ele quais
foram as duas medições dela. Depois que ele souber disso, ele vai saber quais operações realizar no qubit dele para fazê-lo corresponder
ao estado original de Alice. Aqui está uma tabela das quatro medições possíveis e as quatro operações possíveis que Bob
vai precisar realizar no qubit dele com base nessas medições. Bob pode precisar realizar um Zgate, um Xgate, ou ambos para
transformar o qubit dele para corresponder ao qubit original de Alice. Este último passo, onde Alice liga para Bob, aliás, é por isso que
o teletransporte quântico não viola a causalidade. Mesmo que o estado de Bob colapsasse instantaneamente quando Alice mediu
os qubits dela, Bob não conseguiria obter nenhuma informação desse estado até que Alice dissesse a Bob o que ela mediu. E
essa ligação foi limitada pela velocidade da luz. Acabamos de percorrer muita matemática detalhada, então o fato incrível
de que acabamos de teletransportar informações quânticas pode ter se perdido. Mas é realmente incrível. Usando
o entrelaçamento como recurso, Alice podia fazer uma medição para destruir as informações quânticas armazenadas com ela e fazê-las aparecerem
em outro local distante com Bob. Essa distância pode ser de centenas, até milhares de quilômetros. Ainda mais
incrivelmente, este protocolo nem exige que Alice saiba exatamente onde Bob está. Desde que eles compartilhem um Ebit
e possam se comunicar classicamente, o teletransporte quântico vai funcionar. Agora, vamos ver como isso funciona
com o Qiskit e realmente teletransportar um estado quântico em um computador quântico.
Vamos começar com três qubits, um para cada qubit de dados Q e os qubits A e B que formarão o E bit. Nós
começamos criando o E bit. Aplicamos um Hadamard no qubit A seguido de um C knot
entre A e B para criar o estado entrelaçado que queremos.
Então preparamos o qubit Q de Alice em um estado quântico aleatório aplicando uma unitária aleatória mostrada por esta caixa rotulada
U. Então vem o teletransporte. Primeiro o C knot entre os qubits Q e A. Depois o Hadamard no
qubit Q. Então as medições colapsam parcialmente o estado para que apenas o qubit B de Bob esteja em superposição.
Este é o ponto em que Alice ligaria para Bob e diria a ele o que ela mediu. Então Bob aplicaria alguns
gates dependendo dessas medições. Essas caixas com contorno vermelho significam gates condicionais. A primeira significa
que Bob aplica um X gate no qubit dele se o qubit A for medido como um. E
a segunda significa que ele vai aplicar um Zgate também se o qubit Q for medido como um.
Então agora Bob deve ter um qubit no mesmo estado em que o qubit de Alice estava neste ponto aqui após o gate unitário.
Se tudo correu conforme o planejado, então teletransportamos o estado quântico. Mas como verificamos isso? Podemos executar o
mesmo circuit mas fazer uma pequena mudança.
Aqui adicionamos outra unitária bem no final do circuit aplicada ao qubit de Bob. Essa unitária é a inversa da
que aplicamos no início ao qubit de Alice. O raciocínio aqui é que se este primeiro gate criou o
estado quântico que agora está teletransportado para o qubit de Bob, então este deve desfazê-lo, levando o qubit de Bob de volta ao estado zero
estado. Mas é claro que isso desfaz todo o nosso trabalho duro de teletransportar o estado em primeiro lugar. Então não gostaríamos
de fazer isso se realmente quiséssemos fazer algo com o estado teletransportado e se ele estivesse verdadeiramente em um estado quântico desconhecido
não conseguiríamos aplicar uma unitária para desfazê-lo. De qualquer forma, isso é puramente para fins diagnósticos para garantir
que o teletransporte foi bem-sucedido. Se medirmos o qubit de Bob como sendo no estado zero, então podemos ter razoável certeza
de que o teletransporte funcionou. Depois de termos certeza de que nosso protocolo está funcionando como esperado, podemos remover essa
unitária final e realmente fazer algo com o estado teletransportado. Mas por agora, vamos apenas garantir que funciona. Vamos
executar o circuit em um computador quântico. Podemos usar o sampler primitivo do Qiskit para executar este circuit
muitas vezes e reunir estatísticas sobre os resultados das medições. Se teletransportarmos perfeitamente o estado de Alice para Bob todas as
vezes, então Bob mediria o qubit dele como zero todas as vezes, mas com ruído ambiental e imperfeições nos
gates, podemos esperar ver algumas execuções onde o qubit de Bob acaba sendo um. Mas desde que na maioria das
vezes o qubit de Bob seja medido como zero, podemos chamar de sucesso. Aqui temos um histograma dos resultados das medições de
todos os três qubits. A medição de Bob é mostrada como o primeiro slot de cada string de três bits. Como esperado, os quatro
resultados que correspondem ao bit dele sendo zero são muito mais prováveis do que os outros quatro. Então, teletransportamos com sucesso
um estado quântico. Mas veja até onde teletransportamos. Este é um mapa de todos os
qubits no processador quântico que usamos. E no experimento, usamos apenas esses três qubits.
O qubit de Alice estava aqui e o qubit de Bob estava aqui. Então, eles estavam quase lado a lado. Poderíamos ter
alcançado o mesmo resultado apenas aplicando alguns swap gates, que como o nome sugere, apenas troca os estados quânticos
de dois qubits vizinhos. O teletransporte quântico é útil para transportar informações quânticas por longas distâncias, e
estados quânticos já foram teletransportados centenas de quilômetros antes. Para nossos experimentos aqui, somos limitados pelo
tamanho do chip, mas poderíamos tornar o teletransporte um pouco mais impressionante teletransportando um estado entre dois
qubits distantes no nosso computador quântico. Então, vamos tentar isso. Aqui está o nosso novo diagrama de circuit. Parece um pouco mais
complicado, mas nada mudou fundamentalmente exceto que agora Alice e Bob criam seu EBIT compartilhado,
e então se separam. Esta série de linhas e X's representam swap gates que movem
os estados de Alice e Bob de um qubit para outro. Alice sobe para o qubit 1 e
Bob desce para o qubit 12. Então Alice cria seu estado aleatório no qubit 0 com
esta unitária. Tenha em mente que ela está criando o estado depois que ela e Bob já
se separaram. Então Bob já está longe dela.
Então o protocolo de teletransporte continua como antes e Bob termina com o estado original de Alice após suas
operações condicionais. Aplicamos o gate unitário inverso e então verificamos que o qubit de Bob está
no estado zero. E novamente vemos que na maioria das vezes o qubit de Bob foi encontrado no estado zero
estado. Então o teletransporte foi bem-sucedido.
A taxa de sucesso não é tão alta quanto quando Alice e Bob estavam lado a lado, porém. Todos esses swap gates
podem ser custosos e fazer o EBIT degradar um pouco. O teletransporte quântico pode parecer mágica, mas como vimos,
tudo que é preciso é entrelaçamento, um canal de comunicação clássico, e um pouco de criatividade. A proposta original de 1993
que cobrimos neste vídeo formou a base para outros protocolos como o gate
teleportation quântico e é um ingrediente essencial para a computação e comunicações quânticas.
Na frente experimental, os cientistas continuaram a expandir os limites do teletransporte quântico, conseguindo até teletransportar
o estado quântico de um fóton entre um laboratório na Terra e um satélite a 1.400 km
acima dele. E teletransportar estados quânticos através de um cabo de internet clássico com ruído. Se você quiser teletransportar o seu próprio
estado quântico, acesse o módulo de teletransporte quântico com link na descrição abaixo. Obrigado por assistir
e até a próxima.